une production du studio sfr vo sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités
j ph chanter avec moi d'une plante
cette semaine le podcast est présenté
par terriens terriens vous entendez
parler de tes rien de rien depuis
longtemps c'est non comptable on les
aime et on changer la ligne de texte
qu'on a à vous dire donc j'ai ici mon
téléphone le site pour le regarder mais
pour publier aucune information je vais
le garder avec moi c'est une est qu un
bureau comptable qui est spécialisé dans
les pme de 1 à 100 employés depuis plus
de 25 ans l'avantagé de faire affaire
avec eux si vous n'allez pas avoir
besoin de leur expliquer vos modèles
d'affaires il travaille déjà avec des
clients en informatique en
biotechnologie des créateurs web des
jeux vidéo des ces débiles ils vont
pouvoir vous aider à maximiser vos
retours de crédit d'impôt r&d
les cds à eux et multimédia ça c'est des
choses que moi je sais pas trop sais
quoi mais que j'ai l'impression que
therrien terriens qui sont vraiment au
courant de ces quoi on espère on espère
grandement ce nom il offre un système
d'impartition comptable c'est ce que ça
veut dire c'est qu'ils peuvent devenir
votre département de comptabilité à
l'intérieur votre compagnie pour un
frais qui est très raisonnable pour une
pme en fait c'est super intéressant si
vous n'avez pas un terme des comptables
donc utiliser le code sans filtre quand
vous allez prendre votre premier rendez
vous pour 50% sur votre première année
financière ça c'est de l'argent qui vous
revient qui vous restent en fait pour
réinvestir ailleurs dans votre compagnie
merci aux terriens de commande sans fil
podcast oyez mois deuxième commanditaire
du podcast cette semaine planète roster
qui a un commentaire
commanditaires aussi récurrent se battre
car quand même beaucoup ont fait affaire
avec les autres également
notre site web est hébergé par eux qui
en fait au début août est sur nos
plateformes en eau transférer nos
données sur pénétro story ça c'est fait
c'est pas facile
puisqu'il est plus un creux de près
d'être austère mais très rarement son
entreprise mais québécoise le chi chi le
le le qg et à la balle s'est procuré le
siège social puis ils ont un service à
la clientèle
complètement hallucinant 24 heures sur
tu appelles l'autre parle tout à
quelqu'un qui sont vraiment moi qui
connais rien il m'expliquer je
comprenais tout puis je pouvais faire
avec lui puis legault qui a fait notre
site web aussi d'aller paradis que je
salue qui lui connaît vraiment ce il ya
plus il a même cru que j'avais parlé au
téléphone pour une coupe des questions
bien précises et wau genre legault et
sacoches la piste est rapide
c'était simple takk vraiment un superbe
on savait ce qu'était la font paraître
austère et je n'ai pas mentionné ces des
hébergeurs web d'un faux site web ou
quoi que ce soit c'est vont faire votre
hébergement
si vous êtes déjà sur une autre
plateforme qui voulait transférer ils
vont vous offrir la balance des mois que
vous avez déjà payé sur un autre plate
forme gratuitement avec planethoster si
vous êtes une société à but non lucratif
20 et 25 % de rabais et vous avez 25 %
de rabais sur tous vos haches et peintre
auteur avec le code suivant
ph on a jusqu'au 13 union sans résignons
filtre alors rentré se servit un rabais
et c'est merveilleux
dans le fond entre les infos pour les
deux commanditaires pour plus
d'informations voir dans la description
des podcasts cette semaine c'est vrai on
a reçu un artiste j'adore puis je peux
le seul adoré vraiment que je pense que
c'est un gars qui tout le monde à darbo
qui depuis qu'il a atterri dans le
paysage c'est comme unanime que c'est
vraiment vraiment de la bombe
ce qui fait moi ça a été mon album
préféré l'an passé québécois je capotais
en fait j'ai même mis dans le podcast un
peu jaloux parce que c'est de la musique
qui existait en fait un genre de style
qui existait déjà aux états unis ou
encore en anglais mais qui n'était pas
vraiment fait à la manière et
québécoises avec des textes en français
c'est super bon c'est parce que
s'appelle vincent bergeon artistes celi
louanges pas dire que vous connaissez
déjà peut-être pas que vous avez connues
le quelques jours qui traite le monde en
parle go super drôle superchips par
relax j'ai compté des bonnes histoires
de bonnes histoires croustillantes de
tourner son processus créatif aussi
c'est pas belles rencontres piste a
indiqué que j'étais vraiment content de
rencontrer parce que j'aime vraiment sa
musique son or yes
sinon on vient tout juste de finir de
tourner sans filtre vip avec lambert
lambert qui se trouve à être à nos
employés ici au studio sf qui s'occupe
de connecter avec les commanditaires
donc aller voir cette conversation
intéressante c'est disponible pour tous
nos membres pétrone vip donc dirigez
vous vers le lien vers notre pétition
ici c'est également pitchoune la
meilleure façon de nous encourager c'est
vraiment c'est une petite communauté qui
nous supportent puis on aime vraiment on
aime vraiment offrir du contenu dans la
mesure de nos capacités à ce monde là
sinon vous écoutez présentement sur
toutes les plateformes
laissez nous un commentaire laisse nos
rétines parlez-en à vos amis ça fait son
bout de chemin sans sans plus attendre
on laisse avec cette magnifique
conversation bon pas de casque bonne
écoute
[Musique]
yeah yeah sarah berges des lois en
juillet salle humaine y est on s'est
croisé commence à trouver ça c'était le
show dollars g
ça s'appelait d
pour elle et pas plus les gens qui sont
venus supporter dans le show les 11 et
12 les guitaristes sénégalais assane
menzer marché comme une étape les sma
jouissif hawking épique les deux
meilleurs montréal c'est qu'il est ce
que le way we google grog massif c'est
la guide qui joue son histoire soleil
oui c'était vraiment puis comme c'était
les sons je trouve que les leurs la
recherche de ton et en scène ça ça n'est
vraiment s'accroche
bon c'est à toi tu arrivé là en
attendant rien pantoute liste faisait
lui même souhaité inviter un de mes
potes qui m'a dit est mort ce soir c'est
un bon bain depuis la jetée tu m'as vu
moi moi je suis dans la brume jeunes à
entrer en place le podcast les bip c'est
à dabou façon pas de casque car tu t'es
juste envoyé par podcast modération lol
[Rires]
lol
c'est ce qui ce qui choque pas d'amour
qui sema corpo mana mana communiqué bah
oui évidemment médium
ok je sais un texto m félicitations aux
mêmes ouais on est au lendemain des
dénominations
ouais c'est ça en plus je pose des
questions et juste muet la chaussée
parce que c'était pas si tu le dg
chapitre des affaires c'est pour ça que
non c'est ouais c'est ça c'est
technicalité le
un peu qu'on n'a pas loin mais bref moi
j'ai fait en me rendant la bouche je
savais pas j'avais convient de
nomination tout seul
6 3 aussi pour le gala qui est pas
télévisé - c'est selon - c'est aussi est
aussi valable c'est juste que c'est pas
ça passe pas terrible ses pages en moins
25 kg mais ces genres et pour pour le
mixing des pleins de trucs de même fait
que au final ça donne l'album et puis je
peux je peux seulement vous avez là
dessus et je considère que tout le monde
s'est mérité une passe de la gloire un
peu voilà cran de gloire quand betty fox
a fait au moins pour le projet ça fait
neuf nominations
si marc andré cools c'est un peu de mes
amis mais ça c'est un peu m ces quatre
c4 réalisé que golden si ces cas mais tu
en as ton processus qui est affaire déjà
ok je pense que la direction actuelle
c'est vraiment la bonne celle qui est
moite s'est piqué des concrétistes
concrétiser d'une certaine façon par
elle jusqu'à la réception initialement
mais après ça de comme dénomination
toutes ces quantités dit ça c'est
vraiment un projet c'est qui peut tu
peux porter 28 mois on ne finit que
qu'on a fini l'album et
ça a été quand même on l'écouté d'un
trait depuis pour vrai j'avais aucune
deal
j'ai pas trop qu'est ce que je fais ah
ouais quand nous voilà me de wind la
plupart du temps mais faudrait que
l'état dont les infectés mais même à ça
on a fini l'album puis ça tellement été
comme ça a été impliqué en affaires type
il y avait de la presse mais pas autant
de pression parce que en fait il y avait
personne qui m'attendait nécessairement
mais je voulais bien le faire métier ça
m'a pris genre 2 - vont être capables de
réécouter l'album howe est acheté pas
capable t j'imagine qu'avec l'habitude
de ça va peut-être changer même si c'est
la même manière qui est la première fois
de temps en temps parler sur la vidéo le
petit goal et non je vous disais que
j'étais comme trop proche du truc
mais là après ballon mais comme sortie
des tomes tranquillement fait qu'avant
avant que ça sorte était était content
des tonnes mais tu pouvais pas devant
douter de cela ressemble à un coup il
faut que ça soit la réception pis il dit
d'un côté tu peux dire qui ça se fait
que ça sorte que tout le monde capote
qui ça se mette à lever
quel genre la résolution full bonn où ça
se peut que ça sorte pickeu à limitera
pas aux bahamas et euh c'est pas avec ça
marche
je pense qu'on tient quelque chose mais
j'avoue qu'une d'éduquer les gens de
proportions ça pouvait prendre puis
il ya en même temps je pense félix mon
saxophoniste qui comme mon bras droit
dans tout puis il m'a aidé à réaliser
l'album on a fait ça deux baffes 1 était
comme seven ça c'est bon le meur pas un
peu des fois de chanter puis je sais que
moi je sais pas si des fois j'ai trop ça
dans mes affaires pour légende est rude
j'essaie de faire ou un peu des fois où
tu regardes film the mac mais ça va très
vite plaît évidemment on n'est pas des
douches le non plus les fous rires
[Rires]
il est bon aussi pour pouvoir avancer un
peu de pub à finhan et y'avait il y
avait quand même raison le son fait
il demande ce que c'est que ça rejoint
finalement tellement différent ouais t
il du monde de tous les âges qui
viennent au chaud l'essai wild sous
veille de beaucoup d'enfants mais chômé
ya beaucoup de qui dort la nuit une
panthère pratiquement une comptine c'est
vrai mon enfant il n'y avait pas de
chanter ta tenue en bouche pour une
fille puis j'ai entendu ce qu'a écrit de
sa découverte
ouais c'est ça va les filles mais je
suis tout le monde en contre exemple
non mais riffs pigeon faire annuler mais
non mais sa dot et michel algay que dans
la vie on fait chic taris le pied j'ai
fait mon dec mon bac et le pire c'est ce
qui le cache pas les podcasts jeu la
musique mais tant pis quand j'entendis
ton truc même j'ai fait ses cadettes qui
tentant de quoi passer tellement bons
qu'ils étaient comme jalouse je vois ça
tu as déjà fait seul réseau des métiers
jean paul mara jalousie georges bataille
est déjà prestige à mettons ce que
j'écoute lui et que ça aussi puis il y
avait de la musique avec ce genre
vraiment pis ça existait pas alors que
le fasse j'étais comme c'était une
question de temps avant que ça existe
qu'ils comprennent qu'ils fassent puis
tout le pognon des palmistes et à bâle
le mend a foncé avec des teams auquel
j'étais signé chez bonsound aussi là
j'en ressortais les des francouvertes
puis le pays que j'avais fait
c'est la musique que j'ai fait sur
l'album ça fait longtemps que je sais
que si je veux fermer
tu sais pas j'avais peut-être pas
j'étais certainement pas prêt à faire ce
il manqué de l'expérience de vie aussi
dans ce temps le puits puis la ccl
d'autres s'attendent à ce que ben non
ils s'attendaient pas à ce que je
refasse la même affaire nécessairement
ou que même si il savait pas trop ce que
j'arrête mes ont été assez cool de me
faire confiance
sauf que moi je leur ai dit pas dans la
même direction les dom
y a personne qui a fait douter inde le
cnpa qui en a pas
il a dit que je te le métier des genres
d'artistes qui vont aller chercher ça
essayer de mixer les une coupe de soul
et pop r'n'b ou le jazz puis j'ai déjà
mangé un background plus c'est une des
requêtes chansons moins ce que je veux
faire c'est que je vais aller chercher
le monde qui très important sur la
clarté sur fait le break
et puis finalement b je fais du rock
dance mon pays je faisais pour un parti
a fait le break dans ce set
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment mène
justement ça rejoint ce a rejoint
l'argent christ les influences au large
aussi piste assez c'est assez hadji ben
pour tripoli c'est assez accessibles aux
six tués indiqué siemens et comme tout
en même temps saint christ bon de parler
c'est vrai on sait que la cedh mais les
critiques ont été dithyrambiques
olala ça marche tu es c'est t'aime tu
m'aimes tu t'habilles mène à huy
méthodes et dessus têtu complètement tu
as bonne place
x je pense que personne qui lit vraiment
le ou qu'ils aient l'impression de
l'être à 100 % je ne ferai pas autre
chose pour rien au monde
métier je pense que puis la minute
aussi la minute je pense que tu crois
que tu es sur ton excellent et il est
perdu
ah ouais ouais j'sais pas moi je veux
une entrevue c'est david bowie qui
disait barkat et la minute qui était
trop sûrs d'eux tu achètes select select
a perdu lui parce que tu es c'est à
chaque fois c'est des fois c'est sûr tu
peux te manquer tu achètes métier si à
chaque fois un petit stress parce que
t'es pas sur ça ça veut dire successives
quoi tu te garde peut-être essayer de
quoi de nouveautés voilà ce que c'était
comme à oui ça ça marche ça c'est sûr ça
va marcher
puis voilà j'ai trouvé la solution mais
jardin has been mai
mais maintenant en ce moment c'est quand
même cool c'est sûr que je suis dans le
jus le garder sa tête
c'est hier les italiens aux nominations
de la 10 mois mais je revenais ça
faisait deux ans survenue de toronto
puis le celi polaris laver puis on eu
des shows raté de [ __ ] t'as pas si ça
vient mais n'y a pas tellement saf n'ont
pu s'essayer 8 août les moi j'ai comme 3
4 jours semaine
c'est fou ça on se fait et tu met en
avant avant que le projet lèves tu
faisais dessus des shulman tourner
dessus de menthe et non je faisais pas
du tout à fait de chaudes que veux tu
peux pas rouler un teen pas un rodage
mais c'est le genre de maintenant mais
gardent de faire ta bosse de comme
monter sur un stage à toutes les crises
de ce soir pour voir les victimes
étaient toutes faisait tout est pour moi
j'ai jamais trop et j'ai toujours plus
faux cul c'est sûr mais affaire fait
c'est
pendant ce temps là bas ce n'est que des
feuilles des shoots un méchant wathelet
maintenant je faisais des shows de temps
en temps un objet cdd show de matériel
original
le projet lillois ça existe depuis
combien de temps ça fait ben moi j'ai
comme fait granby en 2015 qui est après
ça c'est pendant que je faisais grand
baie jégo barça serait autre que je
m'appelle est loin je pense que les jets
pas de nom machin j'avais eu des bandes
avant
ouais plaisante ayant comme fais toi tu
sais quoi
she works poteau de vincent a place for
green bay 19 ans maintenant que j'ai un
grand sage de 23 mai sagesse millénaire
après mes deux livres thé même rôle tu
tombes 3 puis une heure et quart des
quarts de tons de thé mais moi je peux
vous les jeunes ici l'extrait
tout a commencé en y soit l'intérieur a
commencé dans les toilettes de l'escaut
[Rires]
on parle de quoi avec les lois dites on
s'appelle tous vincent tous attendent
green ah oui c'est un fait que la presse
j'ai fait et je suis sorti de l'eau puis
c'était cool
m j'ai vu un peu ce que j'aimais pas
puisque je voulais faire fait que je me
suis dit bon je vous remet un pli loin
jeu puisque moi je me faisais appeler
demain à 20 cm on est pourquoi c
oncernant
[Rires]
le plus baissé un peu ce quelques pas
mais on avait tout déni cnam un peu un
peu oui il y en a qui s'est fait après
tour à tour feintant se faisait appeler
le corbeau après la croûte
d'après la grand-mère effectivement il
est loin des bassins le maillage ceci
quand même grise comme sa période mais
c'est parti j'ai se déformer des moules
puis musulmane un pays c'est devenu si
devenus les loin je vous même la luz
était pas mal ce poste-là loup puis
maintenant mon cahier de finissants il
marque et c'est tout le monde est
convaincu que changent pas qu'ils
veulent un bon basket ball des gens
moins que c'est comme mon thermique
images estime une citation de voltaire
genre boboche le ou même juste il ne
faut pas avoir peur des louanges plutôt
moins assez sûr pour devenir un actuaire
je te fais confiance
le site de la foire change pour
stéphanie plus d'un mois au travail va
voir par des louanges
[Rires]
parce que c'est celle là pour toujours
et non c'est tellement important qu'on
avait quand même trash et sinohydro
texte si c'est ça tout le monde s'il
faut le garder sur full touch en mai
nouveau genre plutôt c'est juste la
manière c'est juste des niaiseries ben
oui pis toi maintenant rêver qui peut
rapporter de la gagne c'est juste la
merde
même qu'il faut s'asseoir et c'est lui
qui m'avait fait mon bestioles qui
m'avait fait ma citation c'est mn au nom
de nos bons amis qui avaient fait la
sienne puis s'étaient trompés parce que
on n'avait tout en y et z des gens dont
bichard l'uruguay sauf que lui s'était
trompé dans cette traduction fait que
les gérer mr avancé dans son cahier de
finissants avoir qui juste marqueur dit
n'aie pas peur n'aie pas peur je te
regarde au loin et parce que quatre des
enfants
ça se peut que ça se peut pas y avoir un
album de finissants en même temps c'est
comme ça c'est juste oui mais si je suis
ici c'est un peu tendres ont fait ça
c'est ça va être le prochain et on doit
sortir ça c'est tout avant finalement un
peu cruel dans le fait que le sort de
les grandes baies titre hey tu réalises
qu'est ce que tu veux pas faire qu'est
ce que tu veux faire
puis tu décides aller dans ta voiture tu
décides de faire le sari louanges est un
projet ça va être cette direction là
puis est ce que l'étude mais tombe tu
présenté à grand baie est ce que tu en
as gardé ce qui ce thème est ce que tu
as comme conserver du matériel ou a dit
je suis fait opérer à partir un projet
j'ai tout j'ai tout mis ou pouvaient
tous cas p non il y avait quand même des
trucs cool mais
non c'est simple j'ai presque été
capable de scanner tracas wyplay je t'ai
fait déjà mais là-bas en plus qui venait
de montréal fait que tout est encore
vide à l'image avait annoncé jeudi prête
à cinq fois moins
mais si j'ai rien contre le monde avec
qui j'ai tout dit et tout d'un coup le
petit mais on dirait que je sais pas
j'ai pas autant capoté sur mon passage
métier lui profite et file tout le temps
toujours plein de facteurs est différent
j'avais patrie pipe même que j'ai comme
je n'ai pas fini mon dec en musique
écoulée le cours de compos ah ouais
c'est bon contre contrapuntique de moins
de moins ça avec professeurs
par pointe 92 tough à 110 110 quand même
sur des formations comme ceux de dire
que tu coules un cours de compos
combrailles
je comprends absolument c'est comme si
mettons tous types et son écriture
vraiment les bretons sans ponctuation
j'ai envie de montrer qu'ils ont de
fausse affaire de l'ex endredi soir même
afin ouais c'est si on me force à ferme
alexandrins effectivement ce métier en
même temps dit je sais pas moi j'ai
jamais eue maintenant la restriction de
quand tu fais maintenant un travail de
forfaits de l'alexandrin tu fais de
l'alexandrin mais fait jurer pts et tant
qu'ils respectent les règles du coup le
pam est en tournage en cours d'écriture
de romain tu peux écrire comme tu veux
un claque le style que tu veux bien les
saletés de la musique ça n'existe pas
vraiment on était maintenant accorder
les créations puis chacun peut faire son
projet puis à l'éthique ce que ça
pourrait décider mais ça pour exister
genre monte un projet qui joue avec des
bonnes tourner avec genre une course
graphisme l autre qu un genre comme un
artiste fille jean py fait tomber à
l'école pour pour ses pratiques et sa
petite fille prénommée en même temps je
comprenne ce que
on est à l'école puis moitié souvent je
sais pas mais je sais pas c'est quoi
encore mon opinion par rapport à des
fois j'aurai le contexte de création
dans l'école et non la création dans le
contexte écoliers des fois contexte
scolaire je n'ai pas remis moi j'étais
un petit peu trop peu pour je préfère je
comprends même temps très risqué la
musique capsule étudier ces super
mathématiques
ça reste c'est des combinaisons de 12
possibilité tout le monde fait que si je
comprenais le truc mais moi je savais
que c'était celui pour moins pire c'est
qu'ils ont servi de cache veux mes
arrangements ou jusqu'à rien filmé
récemment pee wee me trouve j'ai pour
les u6 après dans ma manière de
fonctionner mais oui si on a parlé il ya
reçu et claudia bouvette lacaunais
parlement a dit el chamaa d'amour je
manquais un peu de faire s'est il amusé
coup j ai pensé nana je fais d'après
ammar mais j'ai dit je pense pas que tu
as fait a rapporté quelque chose tu
parce qu'il ya une différence entre un
musicien professionnel pouvoir être un
artiste musicien frontman maintien
est-il différent c'est ptet pas besoin
de tout connaître la boîte à outils au
complet pour créer quelque chose qui
quittent qui toi tu quittes une équité
ça pue ça peut être mais ça peut être
bon métier tu as besoin d'avoir je pense
une voie unique puis temps tour du monde
pour le coffret outil complet le manager
index la mention mais au moins j'ai eu
assez les coupes du tipi jeu quand même
plus autodidacte d'invités fait que
encore justin dépression fait j'ai pas
envie qu'on me le dise comment le faire
si j'allais le faire de montbard lé fait
que mais c'est vrai et puis il ya bien
des affaires
encore le batteur rappeur admettons le
pit fait juste et une petite fête et aex
phi du travail avec tu développes
intérieur pour juste avoir une bonne
écoute pour trouver les bonnes personnes
pourtant touristes fêtent ces noms c'est
tout le monde le sait qui est tout le
monde qui ont étudié en musique les
savent que c'est pas un diplôme un musée
que votre travail et en musique non non
mais c'est sympa l'analogie moi je sais
ce que j'utilise souvent avec ces
signaux de boîte à outils pitch choisi
le sait puisque va mais comme huawei
qu'il faut les couper le bout de bol il
sort deux équerres quatre tours n'avait
personne à 17h le pire
j'en savais pas que tu sais bien les
utiliser puis tellement d'affaires mais
ton juste à être humain outils commencé
à faire ou même le terme artistes
justement le dead que je trouve que
c'est tough à apprendre le mettons
enseigne le faire un petit saut faut que
tu le fasses c'est la vision c'est pas
parce que tu es très bon technicien qui
quitte une vision ethnique et une
direction artistique qui te dit inspiré
tout ça c'est bien plus justement
écouter de la musique allait voir des
shows et c'est lire un livre parler du
monde de parler de ce qui va te nourrir
que de pratiquer parce que c'était
important aussi moi j'bouge est
pratiquée en tabarnak les prescrit une
presse qui prescrit basque et que je les
musiciens professionnels
mais je peux pas parce que tu fais pipi
puis vice versa désert ce prêt à tout y
est il ya une émergence
la scène des native de québec dernière
bien c'est c'est cyril ce oui qu'est-ce
qui on attribue sackhoff des géants
comme je disais tantôt germé 50 est
venue sur un paquet de 10 et y racontait
que qui avec quelques vous des amis et
il est ensemble dans la rue pour tester
des chiites pitié c'est tous deux comme
histoire c'est vraiment pas commencer
par nathan poème ode jamais dans la rue
mais jérôme pour vrai c'est moi j'ai mon
petit mon chat mais c'est lui qui m'a
écrit une citation de voltaire et aux
jouets dans le vieux québec s'apprête à
traverser le matin puis on allait jouer
le buste est capable de revenir puisse
acheter un mac do l'apprenez c'est pas
mal le battre a prévu un budget elle
annonça les sponsors c'est qu'à masquer
tard qu'ils rendent sponsors ont été des
musiciens il se pose celle qui est visé
c'est pen mané et on on attendait na
tolo par saint jean puis doute qui
viennent par les grecs avec par bojan
compter qu'à bosser qui que dans
vingtaine de palais et ouais je sais pas
trop si vous laissez pas de foyer jouer
maintenant c'est jérôme il y avait le
même âge que nous autres mais pas la
même face il faut changer le temps passé
pour lui reste intacte il était déjà là
y avait atteint
la troisième solution mathieu est
complet le panneau phones équipés les
géo dude annoncé le 12 10 tailles bien
[Rires]
mais ouais quoi kg jamais moi je suis
admettons je connaissais pas vraiment eu
pendant ce temps leur j'ai joué avec
jérôme un puma après moi c'est plus
céder nos amies de filles qui ont plus
commencé à tirer avec avec cette games
autant peut pas prendre arrêté je pense
d'en faire la musique dans le vieux
québec mais des fois c'était proche et
que l'on faisait lancer des poignets de
seine paris jean bouin bang bang aurait
tout à perdre et tout donner c'est tout
c'était un seul saut sama four est déçu
parce que vos petits quête dans 25
salles impunis fois il pas temps
montussan québec le fait que tu
commences ta toune et personnes en avant
parce que je peux pas commencer quand
les et qu'il la personne arrive en fait
c'est qu'il faut que tu joues un nom en
fixant le mur
je m'étonne de bédouines sainte croix et
puis j'ai on a comme deux pièces le
crufc rohr les facs facta trail de de
jouer live par être le fait d'un but un
peu pareil king j'organisais des
chaussées à lévis ouais
j'ai eu des bad beats et même une fois
je comptais sayara jian ont organisé
j'avais loin sous sol d'église
c'était vraiment la savane nuit de la
poésie mon affaire une expo vente mais
c'est quand même cool tu poses et là bas
il y avait trois bennes bien que les ben
c'est un open mic eu comme la poésie
juste parfait brignon mieux conserver
des grilled cheese si on l'avait
complètement copier de pantoum mais
partout mais pas trop avoir pardonné
c'est un peu pareil rendez vous lui avez
vu que j'étais le seul atout torche et
après-vente ça s'est passé la dernière
bosse mais ça avait été vraiment cool
en plus j'ai de l'installer jae bum qui
se plaignait depuis qu'au départ sa
plénitude cracked on était très classe
on avait une famille qui faisait déjà de
la projection sur une théorie c'est
quand même pas comment s'organiser puis
c 'est y avait des doutes qui font de
rappeler encore et québec jean rex avait
le maestro note déjà occupé
il était de la main puis à c'était
vraiment autres comme soirée mais c'est
ça fait que moi j'ai su organiser des
trucs domaine j'ai déjà fait le web et
vous savez peut-être c'est quoi à
l'anglicane à lévis mais moins 18 ans
j'ai vidé mon compte j'ai joué le week
end g20 ben de toronto j'ai invité des
bennes à miami puis mon bain puis on a
rempli d'un geek and away lombez la fois
par exemple c'est que tout ce groupe et
on compte aussi il reste évident
je me suis dit mais la fatigue on a vu
un petit deal parce qu'on donne et ne
profite jamais
j'ai vraiment une bonne personne nos
profits et aux trucs et du docteur
julien en fait tout sauf que finalement
on a vraiment montré dans notre nom
j'avais gardé cet argent le monde se
souvient ses hôtes mais en même temps
ils les niveaux je suis lié au
non-versement la donne et on est allé
donner un gros chèque avec erreur quant
au fait que j'avais dix-huit crise et
même certains accusent déjà absent le
même pas même pas mis ces réseaux
sociaux de sa personne il bender de
toronto ça s'appelait comment ça
s'appelait 10h15 que d'autres options y
avait assez d'eau pour remplir la grille
non c'est nous autres l'ont déjà mais
avec des amis que oui
puis matière j'ai dû leur donner un
cachet de mardi trouvait même testé
comme sûrement le show le moins bien
organisée dans la plus belle salle mais
ça va être cool star games et même que
les colocs avec qui je suis en ce moment
et ont participé des gens bénévoles au
jour les données du cap puis c'est quand
même si avec moi j'ai tout fait
puis a demandé bas ce soit je partais à
montréal avais je m'étais fait du chemin
puis il y avait une fille que je trouve
un kyoto si qui déménage à montréal puis
on a sorti un sens pendant quatre ans la
peine déjà pratiquement ménagers avec
akon et déménager les deux je ne sais
quoi je peux devenir gens souvent gens
tout le temps chez vous une messe café
de serge ça a été annoncé on s'est quand
même bakil toutes les deux elles
rentraient genre ans et non un théâtre
du puy les deux on était de bada 6e
d'actrice point puis c'était tu étais si
c'étaient tous des années ça a été des
années quand même rofl pour un auteur
compositeur qui veut faire ce truc tu
espères tu roule pas sur l'or
je faisais de la tête de seine en plus
fait que je construisais des cités du
livre c'est affreux mais j'allais me l'a
offert des les gens de bar mitzvah
côte-saint-luc halle
je m'attendais en autobus man pichot est
aujourd'hui défendu filage électrique
les dents des chaudes encore dans
l'ouest de l'île pour la saint jean de
quen kippelen en boîte le fruit de
l'amour d'un rouge pour le beurre
mais gérard dine au podcast avec
avec black market avait fait c'est en
tout cas lyon mag nay et ben bongo casse
arrêtés à l'été des coûts de ce podcast
le à libérer ma vraiment sac
non mais l'anecdote était bonne que tu
avais monter ton propre rester aux
francos pour un footeux gouffran côté
que monter les stages tous deux jours
après toujours être subtil de monter la
semaine d'après quand même drôle
apprenait qu'une perceuse le dépense
trou et le pis après j'étais là sous
beach moi j'avais pas d'expérience peau
des c'était lui trois mois je traînais
des affaires pour ceux qui avaient déjà
travaillé là dedans puis il y avait une
forme assez les coffres oui le
maintenant juste parce que je sorte je
sais j'ai des bons bons badri simple
mais à part ça c'est pas tout à fait
ferme
l'efs motif c'est pas la chose la plus
gourmande et le truc dévoila est de
manger une coupe de jolies
voici pour commencer à tout le monde
c'est un expert peut pas tirer blog d'un
pardon ah oui c'est ça comment manger de
la pid sur la route métro top est
illusoire mais ça d'eau qui est dessus
est vite tombée tout le droit qui est à
100% a ajouté quand même mollo a tourné
sur la côte est très bonne équipe ils
évoquent aussi mais ça dépend parce que
si on et l'aiguillon toutes à peu près
dix ans plus que moi ouais sauf mon
saxophoniste félix qui lui était le ti
cul de la gagne puis va-t-il lui à 29
moi j'en ai 23 ouais puis les autres et
34 35 ont baissé souviens d'avoir un
bébé
voilà des fois il amène au sol avec
l'envoi sa blonde avec les tigres
la paire gros gros plus est malade mon
v6 maison genre 12 mois est le pipeline
fut le plus fait sur bb déjà super
copains d'hier ces jeunes gallagher hier
sa main où ils pourraient jouer dans
oasis véhicule est malade mais benzaie
super long j'avais acheté j'avais costa
musée un petit job bête
les affaires le one piece limites qui se
détacher en vol
ouais j'avais fait parce que notre neveu
jake et que les bonnes questions
dentaire c'est le manège dit
choisi au titre aston silver linings de
benneteau ça fait serveurs dont on a pas
de crise il vient souvent un show jeudi
sylvain dany au lieu de ses bons plans
on s'est créé deux mascottes qui
s'appelait ben oui il y avait seulement
la nuit même si sylvain da silva fait
que j'ai fait à son bébé un gros kit da
silva rampling les farces du 6 mois
vingt mille bébés en est comme 4 il
porte déjà devant un boot un fait parce
que leur vie est longue
aie aie aie aie l'ongle tous deux
familles si liam et noel gallagher
battant les deux sont pas mal d'états de
marbre il y avait payé je pense à guy
noël lebon il est quand même ballot mais
fait libres ils sont plus vieux ben
ouais on passe ayant passé la phase raku
et ça n'est pas à toi vu que les bébés
par l'abbé cette ampleur
ça dépend souvent quelques jours avec
des papas les sons of duty là des fois
ci qui ont le plus d'énergie les way
mais à wil s'accordent pas dormir de
toute façon loin mais lui paie 10 et
moins son genre dont moi quand même
c'est les gars aussi c'est ça ça fait
dix millions dix ans d'avancé sur
moulins ils ont fait leur truc puis en
même temps en temps si ça peut être plus
tard panne je pense
toujours la musique est en musique
culture parce que autant conchil avec
les guides ben bernard adamus le pire
les goya et au creusement des enfants de
mon âge on est autant bernard derome et
matt reeves et puis le gîte se
maintenait porte qui donne aussi le avec
qui je peux croiser les cris de la
musique puis mais il faut dire qu on
enfume une crise chat dans le truc là ça
faisait que les gueux y sont affichés
nadeau les connaisseurs et la wiimote à
verdi même à ça on est comme on dit je
pense on y suit on est quand même soft
mais c'est parce que tu peux pas non
plus complètement explosé moi je l'étais
quand même je me suis davis est solide
le soin de se défoncer dans tous les
sens du terme puis des affaires les la
dernière grosse stretch qu'on ait faite
dans l'est du québec ont en effet en
quatre jours
premier soir on josé de la madeleine ont
pas perdu sa lèvre il foule de monde je
pense même projet me faire que ça ne
volait par des locaux et madeline
maginot imaviv lino le mélomane non
sacoche mais ce que n'importe où les
alliés des bons mots et la baleine ah
oui les baumes là bas puis bonbons et
des bambous si les ouais ouais comme des
portes et où j'ai fait que là on a tiré
un peu trop l'attention le mois d'août
commence à me chicaner parce que j'avais
renversé de la bière une madame plus la
balle avait même chitiga donner une idée
j'ai voulu aller pisser en rentrant au
bar les deux filles sont rentrés dans ma
cabine puis le cha m'attendais à
l'entrée des toilettes
[Musique]
demandez moi j'ajuste pouvez vous me
donner
est beau et plus et tarder à effectuer
ces genres de son horrible c'est le lait
ça commence il avait toujours pas joe un
jour raid de la tournée de l'est idée
mais c'était le show était malade bill
l'accueil la bouille tellement c'est que
les dimanches bien le monde sont ils
ceux du propriétaire de la place qui
s'en viennent chercher à l'aéroport et
que son pick up lozano le guérir là
dedans puis on y voter lendemain on fait
l'acheteur du festival du bout du monde
à gaspé on joue une place qui s'appelle
brise bise c'est gros comme is it mais
non la moitié 15 membres
ah ouais puis le père essaye de mettre
un stade je suis d'abord convoquer je
comprends charles puis on faisait
l'after d' iron pis galaxy ah ouais
c'était la seule place tout ce qui avait
un show on joue à 11 heures au québec
aux autres ajouté à gaspé aussi mais
bordeaux non les autres gros gros slage
cleans haute c'est nous autres qui
faisait l'after ils ont demandé de
commencer d' avance parce qu'il y avait
par ailleurs des organisateurs est ce
qu'il faut maintenant c'est que le monde
est peut-être déjà les cuissards foule
il y avait deux trois cents personnes
qui essayaient de rentrer genre puis le
monde commence et agressif même quand on
est rentré dans le bar pour aller faire
notre chaudement ne reconnaissait pas
minutie et on commence à se faire
envoyer chier parce que le coût total en
coin - on se fait si ce qu'est par des
doses les grandes ou dans plus à gauche
on voudra l'onglerie à locquémeau
piédestal en une fille qui rentrait par
les fenêtres a demandé pendant le jeu
c'était assez pour respirable s'étaient
fait jour deux jours deux blocs
persuadés qu'elle après chaude termina
aussi boy mais marquer
la résine et là j'en trouvais ça va
jouer aussi chaque année ce partage est
ce ainsi chaque foyer beaucoup
d'affaires qui sont pas catholiques qui
se passe pas dans les choses qui se
passent aussi sacré souci chaque si
chaque s'est rendu c'est drôle c'est
moins c'est moins hippie l'excellent est
telle que ces genres d bros qui se
fondent exemple sa plage à deux heures
d'après midi le hockey le psy chic et
qu'il utilisa plage comme groupe qui
vient voir la bourgade paisible des
doses assez beau la gaspésie je suis en
même temps j'ai vraiment tripé aussi
chaque pays les six chats qui sont
vraiment qu'on s'en fait pire c'est près
croire différentes puis encore le comme
n'importe où il y en ad brooks font des
bombes dans des endroits quelqu'un on
devrait pas mais aussi cheikh sarr s est
parti puis oui car protesté chose et si
c'était c'était sold out en plus depuis
un bout de temps ça complètement levés
on dormait gens dans le petit chat qu'à
côté fait le fait que les autres au jour
quatre ans joue à trois pistoles
l'après-midi une vieille trois pistoles
c'est un démon c'est à peu près trois
heures pour faire face à cech pour jouer
à 2h01 fait qu il faut chanter ma mère
sa famille vient du bas du fleuve entre
autres fait que les lions d'extérieur
badauds on s'en vient mais les gens des
meules à rester debout le choc je
m'écroule fait que ça finisse et btp
flexos indicateur est arrivé
trop de route parti parti à 800 km était
pas dans ça fait trois jours je me lève
à césar et l'on parle d'eux il faut y
aller en avion
tu as l'air en avion débarqué à gaspé en
avion à l'aéroport de gaspé existe mais
effective c'est pour finir la tournée
des traits était déjà entamée au début
ces quatre jours
oui c'est certain maintenant faire
pendant trois jours le genre la noce et
non le festival d'été joie match est
fake heures au festival d'été jeta
maison je devins genre 6000 personnes
aprem s'en va à la noce j'écoute les
vingt cinq salive la bop et après on
jouait dans un bar trop petit au
festivoix de trois rivières où ce que ça
explose complètement et que tout ça pour
dire ah je les véhicules recruter t pour
répondre à votre question une vie les
gens c'est comment tu fais comment tu
fais maintenant je pense qu'il faudrait
que tu es fort et que tu lèves tu lui
dans l'audience parce que ce n'est pas
la bonne articulation
sa mort sonne à kiel en stage pendant ce
faux comme tu le sais les bleus âgée de
100 ans
mais pourquoi je pense que c'est celle
de ces mots qui parce que dans le sang
c'est moi qui n'ai aucun stress mais
comme comment tu finis ce show leur
maintien en mettant le tu me dis à sa
coche à deux heures
quand je me suis saoul et la veille que
ça fait trois jours que je suis un peu
sagot mène au chaos pendant deux jours
après une brusque le campo vrai le genre
jugé plus capable de faire sur le tir et
puis mes quatre jours de suite mon dieu
comment tu fais à deux heures l'après
midi pour être chef belge était pas de
temps changent au procès le 10 mai
c'est un peu éric lapointe l'est comme
variable mais
aujourd'hui notre pays des caisses
faisait part l'on veut pas équipés pour
qu'il nous revienne je sais je me sens
dormi sur le style du cac ils l'ont vidé
après je me suis endormi genre et
j'étais comme un cil demain matin on est
revenue de se tourner ce soir là en plus
on a versé vraiment c'est finalement mme
on a fait encore l'apartheid c'est
vraiment ça faire des tonnes gt2 c'est
la table afin de gérer les corvées
j'arrête de fumer tout ce qui existe
c'est fini je m'entraîne est quasi nulle
part se promener a eu tort plus les
matins pendant mon jogging matinal
écoute puis charbonnier mon appart sa
part été détruits à manille banque sur
un jardin qui loge à damas comme toile
belle mousse mousse j'ai vécu au maroc
après cet été et puis j'avais une ronde
des chocs financiers
les quatorze inculpés gentil qui à
partir du 15 mai c'est un mois sans
alcool puis je me couche tous petits le
chat jusque là d'un adam abaye away al
ataba bon ok il ya de l'espoir je suis
pas encore
je peux encore sharp la tire t'as pas
coacher le fond du baril cote faut
toucher le fond du baril badé fois
physiquement et enfin de maîtrise à
risque je me suis mis nomination tout à
l'heure on arrêter ça
la veille mais on a un peu éponger le
feq et
on est perdu la coupe c'est ouais pas là
à toronto fait fait que sur quelques
mois près le podcast sa soirée ça va
être plus playstation mais a demandé ou
à des fois le
ça commence à être offre même
psychologiquement maintenant c'est vrai
que ça fait de la pression puis arrive
plein d'affaires c'est comme aussi j'ai
jamais eu autant vécu la vraie ville
cette année il ya plein d'affaires qui
arrive moi c'est des affaires les juges
c'est en janvier jean janvier février
j'ai fait un j'ai fait ma trame sonore
de film je faisais des choses je voulais
commencer le pays je m'en aller
en france puis avant j'allais
south by southwest exemple puis la
veille de partir au texas george
enterrer mon grand père
le mot vers québec in extremis le report
prend l'avion en norvège fait des choses
en va en france c'est big man et c'est
sûr que celui de psychologique
c'est zéro à 100 rue recrue cam à 0
anguille mais le quick en crise
comment tu ta juste assure même que m
comment tu poses de 2 comme post rock
les nordistes mais j'en recommande pas
de quelqu'un qui travaille qui bouge qui
bouge qui bouge qui bûche est un genre
de rapports mon dieu comment tu t'es
juste à ce bain pourrais je préfère
avoir la pression de devoir bien
performé pigé le truc fonctionne qui est
titré si de comment je vais payer le
loyer qu'elle gi joe à vendre pour payer
le loyer
évidemment les changerait pas ça pour
rien mais en même temps le jeu rester
tout seul pendant un bout de lui-même
première tournée en france on en revient
de l'ivoire on est juste avant noël puis
moi ce moment là je restais deux seuls
pillés là on va reporter tout le monde
tout le monde des blondes stade et où
j'ai un bébé qui sans vie de bernard
laporte fray dernier de la grogne
on n'a pas il fait frères la bouffe
d'alfred loisy jo parce que je suis
parti vite et j'ai pas fait le ménage et
professeurs enfin club med par les
calorifères dit qu'elle allait faire de
mardan plus les genevois au moins je
vais prendre une douche je rentre des
toilettes et dames mardi à tarte tatin
été bouchés et je voyais comme des
couacs pause dans le rideau de douche
c'est de voir les deux affaires étaient
pas grand chose mais routier du québec
sq hq dont ckoi qui se passe avec les
ouvrir et d'autres douche puis dans le
fond télé
les plafonds les trucs en fait le
plafond de ma salle de bains va tomber
dans ma douche c'est comme les dents
[Rires]
lorsque tu me laisses les pralines de
chaudes les gens s'engagent à faire des
coupes de cheveux c'est le pas de
m'amener ça va être mais fait finalement
partie admettons le mois j'ai décidé que
j'ai chez jean ménager avec 2 mais bon
chemin de lévis qui restent à montréal à
ce moment lieux qui ont déménagé à
montréal entre temps puis le bep
maintenance et j'ai quand même famille à
maison doit on et romain ont qu un peu
des coups de feu des bâches et macaroni
oui mais c'est will stay parenthèse
personnelle c'est will ce sentiment le
terme médical tracasse que j'ai juste
parlé pendant six mois c'est moi qui
réponds fois en cinq ans non mais c'est
juste que je l'étais à ce que tu faisais
parce que tu étais tu es 4,1 qu'une
fille où j'étais sans rancune figea les
mama ou sk et puis là pendant ton appart
puisque genre détecte fenêtre quoi tout
arrive chez vous pilotez du seul petit
tatouage n'est pas du tout d'être sont
chez vous plaît c'est le cas c'est quand
même wilt à web etc après moi c'était de
ma faute c'est que
la piscine non c'est mon problème mais
en même temps c'est mauvais aussi qu'un
jack et de téléphone passés ces exemples
moins d'enfants genre ça comme finis ma
blonde deux jours après je me suis trop
saoul et je trouvais pas ça de la place
émilie-gamelin
je me suis fait jack jack et mon
téléphone par un gang et c'est clean
c'est la vibes émilie gamelin eric est
rentré à ma défense comme encore ghost
writing se régaler oui il sera contrôlé
par la bibitte fois depuis que tu es ce
un assez bon mais oui mais non saison 2
c'est fini que non mais à ma défense je
me sentais bien fait maître d'école ont
ouvert parce que je tombe become fucked
up d'un coup au monde où tu étais au
jardin non j'étais avec le baroque et
non non je t'ai jeter dans le fond
c'était c'est quand même ce contre
histoire c'était la forme cet été
j'étais guitariste d'art le show ma
meilleure comédie musicale
ok moi dans le fond on était au théâtre
st denis oui c'est serna deux mois puis
on était un morceau qu'est née chris de
burgh et ouais vraiment vraiment
vraiment content d'avoir fait ce qu'il
sait la première médiatique ce soir le
enveloppé http https l'oiv nuit venant
premier à prendre coupe de bière après
tipi jeter quand même par un peu moins
long mais je te donne parce que georges
stephen king fatigué je tenais en jupe
il était justement salomon moyen bien
dans ma vie personnelle si tu es comme
un peu à côté avec lui un métier je
prends une coupe de de cannes qui modère
tout va bien c'est un bundle
j'ai un job daste georgie fait de
vraiment pire genre souvent pays
infectés loi je suis good the bad plus
tard d'armen à 3h15 wifi ni pythie comme
je me retourne mitchum sont partis
chacun leur barrage comme ça
vos choix qui j'allais prendre prendre
le bus en banlieue de québec l'autre à
la baisse pis le redis je me place
émilie gamelin
j'attends la biopile et jusqu'à 25 cm
sans problème ça vraiment pas besoin de
jouer un petit carré de gazon mais je
fais la confortable avec le mode survie
des gains trop chaud picchi trop fatigué
mais je pense que c'est une bonne idée
de me coucher l'été je me couche le même
chiffre qu'en même temps après jean
grenet a pressé comme et demandant ce
genre jeter littéralement couché avec
mon celle qui met un gros gros colon
j'avais pas de pot de colle mon celle ci
fait quatre personnes allaient rentrer
là dedans est rentré dans la grandiose
au baba dans la bio j'aurai je pète à la
gueule c'était d'avoir trouvé nanana de
bonneville rocade les bonnes vieilles
menace
pis le genre futurs prêts à madame et à
faire changer mon identifiant apple je
pouvais plus rentrer dans mes enfants at
il eu stitcher le fait que les amène
justement sur ces premiers taxis jaunes
chine où je suis quand même en jeu tant
que défenseur je me couche même genre
logis en plus j'avais laissé mon sac à
dos haute aux saint denis avec mon ordi
dash 8 et 10 dommage venir chercher ce
qu'il fallait jamais québec chaque jour
passé leo pas nier ce fait que sheen ou
pas de sel pas d'ordi aucun moyen de
communication aucune technologie
j'ai pu de blondes genre l asaph il est
pour moi
l'homme est d'atteindre le fond le sait
comme seule chine ou trauma le rythme
est mêlé mythes ait choisi ce thème
l'acheter tout seul comme trop mal au
coeur pour vraiment se lever 12 5
minutes et juste coucher dans la douche
avec l'om qui tresse la face c'est rien
d'autre à faire toi même tu en prends
tout pour aller au couche-tard aux
bordelais rim pa [ __ ] et le var 11h30
je crois qu'il faudrait aussi un dernier
chercher mes enfants le jour mon ordi le
jeu vous amène tout la marque et ph
métrie mais qu'est ce qui se passe avec
les instagram chaud c'est adamo et
m'envoie un screenshot genre de deal
instagram du studio c'est avec liszt
message de menace la description d'un
mandat delmas
deux semaines après j'étais parqués
derrière c'est justement pour pour mon
show ça en fait georges fini mon show
comme tariqa je prends direct ligue 2
heures et demie dans son téléphone c'est
ma cousine et musique et la police vient
de l'appeler pour parce que ton char il
tempêté daphné qui ont pourri ça te
rejoindre puis lyon lyon je sais pas
comment ils prouvent qu'ils sont rendus
jusqu'à ma cousine
le char d'ailleurs justement je vois que
mon char l'espace ont pété jeu j'ai
trouvé la branche art dans mon champ
j'avais deux amplis même j'avais pas de
guide
peut-être quelqu'un de pressé on a
rempli sa se veulent moins bien mais les
ambitions de camp lui puis je trouve
dans mon char une crème à face vraiment
une crème que pour filles bien un
glossaire qui est je pense que c'est une
fille te maeva nuance elle parce qu'il
ya marie amérique rija sur instagram
c'est que son annonce des faux culs
beach 112 qui est
[Rires]
votre profil est grand temps de se
refaire à la veile téléphone de damas
prône cette fleur the mirror après
bikini avec une cagoule avec mon frère
si bien qu'il ait déjà un iphone c'est
vrai exactement à pia qui mène le nombre
d'heures d'énergie que j'ai mis à aller
voir la police a pris apple pour qu'ils
trouvent une solution pour mon intention
un peu parce que jean simon a été
finalement à ce jour à mes potes a même
pas de bon goût est le décès du barça
c'est bon je vais la voir lesquels
audition avec simon j'ai déjà pu quitter
les aventures de starman avait voulu lui
avec un an mais c'est lui avec perruque
fun qui en fait le texte gens qui disent
elle sait pas que j'en fais que c'est
pas du tout c'est vraiment content de
voir paquet c'est pas qui n'a non plus
quand on est ce que vous allez le voir
sakho joue aussi arrêter le podcast
[Rires]
l'épisode a claqué tout la marque
n'existe pas de casque
c'est le lycée la sommité jour revenir à
ton ton retour ton retour apprécié chez
vous seul qui décide de déménager en
appart avec d'autres boys puis se met
entièrement tu pourrais te payer un
appart seule maintenance et tu pourrais
vivre en colocation match et c'est une
des premières fois que j'étais
célibataire que je ferais laisser vivre
seul mais ça m'intéresse de voir l'autre
l'envers de ce mal avec les salles non
contre contrat est proprement au contrat
je regarde la dent dure et quelqu'un qui
se bat on voit fait que ça crée souvent
des conflits mais mais toi tu sais tu es
tu vraiment su vraiment décision de
comme j'ai besoin de ça j'ai besoin de
sentir que quelqu'un d'autre avec moi
dans mon quotidien sexy collet ben si
juste pour me faire décrocher de style
de jeu fait couper les cheveux puis
quand charles millon rythme moins juste
parce que je me suis dit bon vieux
bolides et cholet continue mais t'es
juste pour comme sortir un peu de mon
espèce de loupe le de musique
admettons le ça finit que les les gens
qui m'importe que je côtoie ben
maintenant c'est déjà avec que je
travaille c'est drôle de
le rapport - pompiers iva correct parce
que finalement ces gens faire de la
musique pas plus ce soir mon projet tout
il ya quelque chose de même on fait des
shows puis toutes les 6,6 à peu on peut
pas juste pas de chine pas de charge
c'est un peu le dax à sunrise embarque
le pire moment donné on va débarquer ça
va être le messie non c'est ça fait que
je voudrais juste aller faire mes
entrevues puis tout puis finalement
c'est hier chez diane est venu avec moi
puis en italie
de fait j'ai fait rencontrer beach à
12h05 bon vieux monde 4 à 8 cm 2 oui bac
le délit villenoy aux échecs et ses îles
peuvent pas parce que j'ai même des amis
aussi des fois qu'elle est la lettre t
elle avait changé mais aux autres et
c'est resté pareil je suis fils qui le
tue vue et pendant les lassus du monde
changé envers toi peux-tu remarquer soit
c'est pire des foyers demande en fait
c'est parce que dirigeant moi j'ai
remarqué tout le monde parle d'eux comme
un hôte et j'ai pas s'imagine ma vie des
fois c'est où
quel est ce que tu veux dire qu'est-ce
qui fait ton moi j'essaie de magie ta
vie jumanji j'ai aucune idée
petit ouf à tanger pas qu'on puisse le
var var que ça pourrait avec lui mais
assument des trucs
des fois c'est moi ou comme un chez soi
je peux pas nier ou thé ou comme un
soufflé que tu caches tout partisan pour
ça il va j'ai démarré on sert aussi au
moins t on au moins des petits des
petites connaissances que ça peut valoir
c'est assez pour pouvoir vivre seul
travail bowie non mais c'est vrai que ma
vie ça va bien et enregistrent ces puits
mais c'était fixe mais en même temps
c'est que c'est comme mon ma job depuis
mon tout ce que je fais dans vie c'est
comme construire un terrain en
psychanalyse le genre le l'inconscient
de le concept est le genre de sur moi je
fais le voeu que les littératures fois
il est le seul qui est dans le fond
c'est finalement les monts sur moi c'est
ma job c'est l'image que je projette
c'est l'image que je cultive pic
maintenant comme rendu un peu une autre
personne carrément soins les lois c'est
un fait qui fait que les ivy lui même
jacques est pendante à dix membres
effectifs ça ça va de décéder fois
s'imaginer que je fais fort de cache
cache une foule ou que le choix du jura
du jeu viril hollywood sur les gentils
une file maintenant peu sa brosse de bar
qui me parlait à des lillois je m'achète
3d je pensais que tu étais vraiment plus
belles vues comme un fou mais ça se fait
que quand même la relation avec les gens
ou ou des fois le c'est drôle les genres
du monde je trouve bible qui est mort
non même quand j'étais allé faire en
direct de l'univers ces missions bon
déficit d'attention d'austérité le
christ qui c'était lui en direct de
l'univers radio canada hockey 70 invités
dans la remet sa santé lui des eaux le
monde jeunes france beaudoin est une
grande fan la france beaudoin est belle
avec les animateurs de l'épicerie champ
c'est vraiment drôle
il y avait trop de monde puis moi je me
sens un peu
nous admettons que j'attends le plus
jargal à côté de monde c'est jean marc
andré grondin s'allume and growth ta
musique jusqu'au ier métier après ça te
remet en perspective qui est un maniaque
donc moi je peux voir les autres
les autres peuvent faire barton ou un pc
finalement le passé une journée avec
tout ces gens là jean py même si brusque
et pau et cette journée là je pense j'ai
plus joué la porte et smash bros avec
tout le monde était là haut des seins
est rude et ruelles situées à l'aise
dans les pilleurs pigeard qu'il aie aie
aie telle personne ici genre dit il faut
que je parle à tout le monde
12-7 dérange pas vraiment bonjour est ce
qui m est tombé la question la question
c'est est ce que maintenant c'est
l'événement pilleurs tout juste à là
dedans betsy comme of the world qui ait
jamais eu a déjoué à ce match et nous
mais je pensé comme un mix des deux
parce que je pas capable d'aller faire
du pire nécessairement mais c'est en
même temps gamme jaws exode le pire jeu
comme pas trop trop bon être bien
transparent avec tout le monde s'épie
puis cinq puis je vais vous parler
d'affaires ben personnel puis j'ai pas
de trop belles soeurs plus jeunes drogba
puis finalement je pense que j'ai réussi
à bien le faire le pilleur puis je finis
finalement le montrent de vrais
investissements entre que j'aime penser
que je joue vraiment cool je me plais à
penser si ce que tu me disais tantôt
avoir contenté tout à mayotte et c'était
les nominations pour eux
l'adisq puis la musique
exact puis tu me disais je préfère la
partie avec avec la gagne tout allait
vraiment les plus gros party au genre
une occasion d comme j'ai pas côtoyer
tout le monde sait puis moi je vais
aller voir mes beauty et youtube
c'est ce qu'il ya c'est pas chaussures
mal adaptées de l'adisq mail hier
c'était pas la plus grosse affaire mais
c'est sûr que wade fois moins
si c'est ça c'est ça ta date grandes
villes parce que c'était jean demannez
même si au moins ce qu'il faut noter
c'est que d'autres parents comprennent
ce que je vis puis en même temps des
fois des gens qui sont à l'extérieur de
la musique peuvent pas comprendre ces
mêmes années c'est que tu te ramasses
dans un genre de l'eau plus de parler de
tout ce qui s'est passé c'est une manie
même si tout le monde est super le fun
puis cgt 90% des gens qui m'importe en
ce moment on sent des travers la culture
ça fait du bien la dette d'avoir le tome
qui dit coupe de cheveux en droit acquis
mais sinon je ne me rends pas malade de
bragg métier connaît un plus bas depuis
le jazz et pizzas il faut blâmer mais
justement il crie ce match il me disait
dis moi ça me fera du bien l'avouer
miqueu genre chose notre vue d'illustrer
c'est un peu la main georgis quelqu'un
qui dit les vraies affaires
quipo tout le temps c'est des fois je
t'aime kate atteint le statut t'es tu
peux avoir
citant tour juste des yes men que
demande qui disait à quel point ces
bombes des beautés ça sera pas service
parce que le genre je te demande tu peux
partir il initie les lui c'est un
exemple de goren les plus à un prix le
plus grand des semaines que j'ai
rencontré
thibault paulette pour le statut qui a
atteint 26 comme il est trop relax pin
normal puis joris karl huysmans
glandulaires plus être que t'as pas tout
le temps maintenant puis
non c'est clair très puis c'est cool qui
est dynamique les deux je pense que
c'est un espèce de double inarrêtable
vraiment puis puis ouais mais c'est
encore le après ces types de l'image que
tu projettes l'image qu'on pense me tire
la majorité du monde si tu réussis
souvent en musique ou dans n'importe
quel domaine je pense même si c'était
pas ça va où le monde iront pas envie de
devoir puis baisse et ceux du travail
d'arrache-pied mains de pays
il y arrive il travaille vraiment fort
qui est su partir avec tout le monde
même en pire pour pour revenir aux
événements de pirogues en parlais tantôt
le petit dictacture t'avais télé sur moi
que le personnage la scène
et puis tu ne semble pas être cette
personne là quand tu rencontres des gens
fassent des feuilles c'était pour parler
min
mais j'ai l'impression que dans le
showbiz québécois pour l'avoir côtoyé
juste un peu j'ai l'impression qu'il y
en a qui reste leur surmoi dans des
événements comme ce jeu précis je pense
même feeling là j'ai l'impression qu'il
y en a qui perdent pas cette carapace le
qui donne quoi ce cas accès au mois à
tout le monde c'est tandis que tandis
qu'eddy liant nos artistes comme toi qui
semble donner le titre est venu ici
c'était pas pour rester un personnage ne
s'était pas mais j'ai l'impression que
ce n'est pas le cas de tout le monde
dans ce milieu là moitié c'est qu'il
faut que tu sois il faut je pense qu'il
faut que tu aies fait fort parce que
montage du sud pour personne qu'il aime
mais chaque mois le ca vaut bien mais
veut passer comme toujours faut toujours
se confrontent ton propre ego un peu
puis des fois je pense qu'anne et que
compensent à aix et un peu de se faire
un front simple une carapace qui est par
le fait qu enfant je viens juste de
répéter ce que tu dis oui mais moi je
pense que des fois c'est off puis moi
des gens qui sont même des fois j'ai un
peu la misère moi j'ai moins ils me font
part les gens qui ont entretemps comme
en train de calculer un peu loin c'est
lui c'est un peu ça une tasse on soit
comme ce matin avec toi métro sma pour
quelqu'un comme qui connaît pas tant que
ça aux tic y ait un match fou grinch
nationale arrive le but de déstabiliser
je réfléchis pas 28 mai
est un chouette et puis
hum ça il y en a qui le font mais à fin
de la journée je pense que quand même
bien ne peut pas trop te le permettre
c'est moi j'étais mené j'ai entendu le
doute qui nous expliquait je pense que
master class avec un geek que c'était
quoi avoir une carrière
granby puis quand même désolant
- sur le successeur jean sur les
chansons c était comme métier tout les
gens qu'ils soient croyants montante va
croiser en disant que c'était ce matin
va lire croisée de toute façon parce que
ça ne sera jamais une ascension
constante du fait qu'après b s'est fait
vite les cdo tout envoyer chier un
montant d'une personne qui veut qu'ils
voient tous secteurs
la chute le site puis après bon puis si
tu le fais vraiment juste pour assurer
ses arrières
mon rôle c'est avec celle d'avoir
exagéré ce matelot frisson un vrai frein
qui était vraiment intéressé pauvres et
au monde du jeu c'est vraiment bien
veilleurs parce que si tu es vraiment
fin mai que à l'autre d'où la marche sur
l'eau depuis à l'autre fait si le
aftermath à travers contout est bonne ce
match et essayer de rester à naples est
l'adjoint c'était parce que même s'ils
n'en sont eux pas envie de mingora avec
le monde mais au moins le monde le
respecte et c'était pas vrai faux cul tu
es ouais mais après ça c'est jamais
facile parce qu'ils étaient toutes en
représentation tôt même puis c'est je
pense que vous glissez un moment un
autre l'été mais fabre est bien passé
d'être capable d'être né avoir
l'humilité des x 10 x kaput si tu sais
pas je me suis perdu jeudi dernier deux
minutes de revient mettons dans son
ascension notons un moment déjà qu'il
faut que le morginois homme qui dit hey
hey joe white witch tale à faire ou pas
vraiment mais à date
pauvre et c'est pas super des fois j'ai
un peu une grande gueule mais sinon
sinon adapte n'ai je pas encore payé une
fois jetés au festivent de
baie-saint-paul pile
j'étais un peu le givi rica qui quand on
faisait les moines
je voulais avoir plus de bois dans mon
monde le sait parce que si je m'en
tamponne je veux guérir puis à fin de
l'été je serai plus capable de chanter
ok le fait que les jeux bonnement tant
pis pour moi ce n'est pas vrai non des
fois c'est peut-être ce niveau par terry
qui m'a mené lors des fois je vous fais
savoir il faudrait peut-être te coucher
mais sinon c'est le temps sinon à date
j'ai pas eu trop de frictions mais je me
débrouille 6 et ont laissé l'exemple
vient pas là que se fait maintenant une
fois les l'a dit ce qui s'en vient et
pleure comme l'album a fait son chemin
mais la fête car pas de cage la sortie
parlement savoir si un fait
ah ouais ça va
vous sortez trois ou quatre semaines
dawn a toujours trop semaine ça va être
à l'écouté expansion pack est disponible
sur internet nous l'a prétendu accord
mais est vraiment bon mais est ce que
c'est la lignée directe et après l'album
à ce que ça va dans d'autres directions
qu'est ce qui supposerait que ben moi je
pense c'est comme un peu les idées que
j'avais un peu niveau style sur l'album
un peu ces stéroïdes à west ham et on la
tourne que j'ai sorti quand même ça vous
parle
à tampa bay c'est elle qui ressemble le
plus au reste de l'album it's ok et puis
el basti c'était la première que j'ai
fini nong qui en même temps mais j'avais
pas trop le temps de faire un clip puis
j'étais jambes et pourquoi pas on va
filmer t1 était d'un premier album tout
ce que ça va bien je dis aujourd'hui il
sortit le vicky sharpe j'ai vu leur taxe
c'est fait j'étais quand même temps cet
égoïsme et moi ça m'a fait est jeune on
le voit cros greu dans les denrées ont
marqué je regardais avec l'accueil un
gros plein sans gros gros bébé et puis
des buts inscrits et non monétaires on
était chez les ch et la mer
le pam ont baissé
chicoutimi au buffet de la couronne à
côté de la piscine mort par la cour des
copies ce film est seul
et puis ça c'est aussi ça c'est malade
avec les codes c est pas compliqué il
n'ya pas des gaules dans le bain puis
ses démembrements juste 25
on est content des justes bien manger
boire une bière les personnes qui par un
peu penser à goulot sur l'espèce d'ego
triple votre logis sobre vous demandons
ni correct il reste plus grand chose
dans l'aprem et hautmont atrache porte
sans doute mais puis et c'est celle-là
on a parlé de paix oui on voudrait que
je commence à avoir ma journée encore
fait comme j'ai pas la taxe en mai
tandis qu'allaoui ses baies fixé c'est
l'éclipsé vraiment plus éclater une
c'est sa fille tu es avec le propos mais
l'oeil d'autres traque le vraiment plus
y en a une qui s'appelle park ex qui est
vraiment vraiment plus ça ça reste
supérieure le saut ça doit être ma plus
intime je pense que j'ai écrites les qui
parle vraiment de ces cétacés dans ta
face aux de quoi ça veut parler mais je
pense je les fait et je pense une des
plus belles tenues écrit dans ma vie
c'est double 23 ans
non mais vraiment un stock après ce tir
deux autres tonnes dont je suis vraiment
fier qu'il y en ait qui le jugent plus
poétique aux environnementalistes en
plus de dents fait que je suis content
de pouvoir un peu parler de titre même
si bon encore le je sais pas si mon
message est clair aussi je me pose pas
constructif non plus mais là c'est pas
non plus large dollar dacca
avais tu sais pas je pense pas qu'on est
obligé d'apporter des réponses ou des
propos n'en discute hadopi le monde irsn
ce qu'il a dit au président sur la très
bien et une autre le monde y est pas non
plus robert nilsson qui j'avais et je
pense qu'elle est il ya un peu mou vente
de son personnage lorsque je ne connais
pas assez pour me prononcer là dessus
mais j'imagine que tu as envie d'évoluer
dans vis et puis affecté comme olivier
frapolli pas qu'il faudrait évolué de
tout mais j'ai pas humanité jeudi à
québec tout le monde au lac saint jean
on dirait vraiment que c'est quelque
part avec cuba qui avait maladie le fait
juste à attendre comme tente à jean
robert nelson bibeau canada jorda c'est
parce qu'il dit l'américaine
c'est un ailier fort ségolène infecté
cgu latine avec puis - bc saint-gall ces
gens mais bon après je veux pas me fixer
peut avoir la tête quand je vois les
revoir métier qui passe à un peu mais où
le jazz et j'ai tellement écouté jacques
rivière - c'est autrement fait comme
comprendre que le rap c'est pas juste
non aux fans sa tactique ou mais moi ça
me parlait moins regardé derrière ton
épaule toute la ville 132-1 proche du
pont mais je sais même pas si bien de ce
héros en fait le fait qu'ils aient cette
traque le kelley cellphone on est un
petit peu plus d'heures qu'un petit peu
plus et pop
on est allé chercher des sonorités
différentes c'est beaucoup plus produit
puis aussi l'autre tunda vente c'est
vraiment plus super électro et puis on a
rajouté des plans d'affaires au travers
j'ai même foule de tension dans cette
chanson je te lis plus et je dis bon
hiver le traitement de la voie d'eau
mais curieux on le 2 janvier puis il ya
sa pile l'avant-dernière track sur le
psn tournée je sais j'approche un gars
qui s'appelle maquis lavender bah oui
bienvenue
madame livni au podcast sur le podcast
d'un mot c'était moi qui faisait
attaquer mais qu'il est malade et c'est
google qui mêle je les ai rencontrés une
fois on devrait passer ça lui celle à
l'exacte droite comme ça avec moi je
pense pas lui fournit chance en mai
[Musique]
je venais me réveiller j'avais dormi à
l'hôtel ben sahar otages avaient dormi
deux jours le facteur stress et head of
state ce soit je viens de me réveiller
ou stop bar c'est le rock est fini
maintenant délais mais l'orque mais
l'effet clé je le vois il s'arrête avec
les bennes lindsay lui ttc mois les
wings et on s'est parlé john cale à
bahreïn et roanne s'étaient déjà
redressées un bounty m'avait demandé
moi-même d'être sur son album puis moi
j'ai pas j'ai pas eu le temps
finalement le mais l'attrait qu'ils
étaient vraiment folle en même temps ce
match week-end ou quatre en une journée
oui je suis déçu pas salubre
on s'est parlé on se connaît ouais ouais
t'es pas content d'avoir soulevé le
risque est accru sur ce trailer est
tellement forme j'ai envoyé la traque
moi je savais pas que j'allais dire
là-dessus pythie j'y vais un peu beastie
boys là dessus quand même tu puisses la
barre à madrid
tu es exprimé traque le plus de 10
mondial d'étaler dans toutes les têtes
la musique au complet bon iver beastie
boys données pis les beastie boys c'est
juste parce que j'étais je rappe plus
dans celle après ça le monde pense aux
mains ce qu'ils veulent si c'est bon ou
pas quand je pense c'est cool c'est
quand même 15 mai la maman dont je le
fais excuses mon argent c'est comme un
beat vraiment
et genre et pape rapide mais on a
rajouté du drom qui fait comme en double
thème un peu fait comme diderot mendy
était juste la drôme qui arrive des fois
au travers le drame acoustique de tours
2 pas de casse pompon mais avec là il ya
tout ce qui se passe mais j'ai de la
disto d'envoi puis un espèce d'intro
genre de fausses corde avec une espèce
de solo à la tante de quatre jours de
baisse
que lui arrive même en jah tool works
défonce la preuve je peux le comparer à
lui nécessairement métier si c'est bon
le manneken pis m'envoyer seul j'ai
envoyé la traque 7 heures et 9 heures pm
ouais après midi j en vois ça 7h à 8h et
12h au nom jackson en revenant chez nous
à 00h30 leur verser à l'effet de
m'envoyer sa super bien produit plus
j'écoute super bien produit janvier
mixer son vocal pitre à wil leur ajouter
sa touche famille c'est juste pour
niveau non non non bravo reloge pas bon
les fans regrettent et puis en plus dans
le bout de la traque j ai fait fuld
espace effective d'un coup d'oeil plein
des danses et l'atmosphère sonore
il y avait de l'espace pour lui fait que
ça sonnait bien typique mois après il
restait à ce que moi ma voix était mal
mixé plutôt parce que moi je ne sais pas
encore dans m'efforce d'être capable de
le femme à cause de pessah foule marché
betty j'ai vraiment appris le là dessus
mais plus finalement je pensais tout le
monde est égal dans tracks mais il ya
été fait ça vite le pipi le bien fait il
ya ce puits mais milieu d'autres sur les
tracks go qui s'appelle robert robert
défait de l'électro est vraiment bon si
vingt dix
lui même avait touché avec tantôt après
le podcast justement un an j'ai dit que
j'allais vous plaît venez chez moi
jamais dormir m6 et lui m'a aidé plus
pour cette raclée justement vu que lui
seul connaît plus le sait plus
travailler les les logiciels tels que y
est ce la dernière très qu'en plus vous
allez voir c'est genre ça je pense je
sais pas je vais compter au podcast
wagner n'excédant pas 10 mais la donne
après quoi une fois jetés en france puis
on est de fait un show dans une tout
petit bled qui s'appelle arbois mais ils
font du sport avant les boeufs depuis
deux ans on jouait même genre d'une
maison des jeunes c'était jean le show
s'annonce être vraiment patent valable
dès lors qu'une dans le câble puis
finalement b
c'était la fin du monde ne parle que
fait qu'il ya plein de jeunes qui a
retourné chez le parent avec les
finalement bon ajout genre devant
cinquante personnes dans une petite cave
le genre encerclent le classique là un
pull à est allé faire une tournée en
france doit jouer dans des petites et je
vous ai clichés le petit imaginé ça
c'était vraiment cool puis finalement
ben après le show ont-ils tous dehors
puis le beh oui un des dégâts dans le
bain qui comme les immuniser de geisha
cliff il a pris part il faut regarder
pendant le gilet des comme si si si tu
vas lui aujourd'hui je vois comment
sait-on gear mais encore bondi ok je
vais aller vous aujourd'hui plus belles
finalement je les invite sa note after
fait que bloquer les jo gook et écoute
les filles ont un chargement d'un
acheteur sur la manche inaugurale
consorts je pense argens tantôt plier
comme basso cambo ok parfait mais aussi
que nous autres le thé la ville
on retourne dormir à besançon fait que
moi ou et bégard je m'organise ok je
suis les filles sauf que je me ramasse
moins deux villes plus loin dans l'autre
sens je me ramasse dans un espèce de
house paris
comme si j'étais à montréal puis je me
ramasse à mont-saint-hilaire ouais au
sud qui est ma maison de parents jean
gross paris que les filles sont pas sont
pas tant les pièces aux poteries ne
connaissent pas vraiment percé est fini
mais j'arrive les autres forfaits tout
c'est que tu arrives le câble
ouais je mets à voir l'espèce d'alcool
de patates de la bauge en plus
finalement mais ces sages avait pas de
place où dormir fait clair je suis deux
des filles qui s'en vont chez leurs chez
les parents d'une petite fille clémence
a dormi vidéo avec les deux filles les
parents sont la base agricoles dès le
lendemain matin il est inquiet qui est
descendue rencontré des parents
finalement rien passé moi je suis un
gunner qui arrive le ipod
je voulais mourir j'étais à 45 minutes
on veut bien de moi ce que t'en aller
tout ça pour dire que le lendemain
présentant les filles il triple écoute
sur leur téléphone y avait une
conversation de groupe
ouais puis il y avait une dingue qui
était complètement tord celle en début
de journée lundi
ouais puis les vnf a envoyé un message
vocal sur la conversation de groupes
genre à 4h30 du matin puis ben moi je
souhaite l effet envoyé - ce au plus
crise parce que je vais faire une traque
avec j'avais un truc instrumentale j'ai
mis le truc
mp traits d'une fille que le marché
français est malade lui c'est bon le pij
en bonne joueuse parce que je leur
envoyais puis on dit c'est vrai c'est
comme un invité formellement tacler j'ai
juste puisque ça très dommage de
dissoudre inflation d'affaires ça
commençait et je suis des fonds c'est
non mais laisse tomber j'aime courir bon
peut-être pas 10 km mais mais presque là
le pire le pire du pire si je vais
devoir rentrer dans la chambre de ma
mère en mode sneaky quoi en mode ni vu
ni connu j't'embrouille alors qu il est
4h30 du matin tout va bien
franchement tout va bien effective sa
fille tu es sur la traque à la vc 1
bronze
j'ai déjà ça a été compliqué dj city way
6 et puis après les galions repris
matraque
puis l'on enregistré live sauf que les
lions s'ils ont toutes baissé les
mesures puis genre le tempo pour des
fois stoppé pour bien l'entendre fait
qu'à sa tête se tenant s'appelle arbois
foumane quel bois laisse toi la vie à
tenter la traque pigeons oui mais une
chance parce qu'il a débuté comme
renvoyer plier they come & stay pas elle
en question dont j'avais le contact avec
les gérants vois pas ce que j'allais le
poster que gens m'ont tracklist puis les
jeter comme beaucoup j'espère que vous
aimez ça m'a juste réécrit pas les
fassis et messages j'ai juste vu jean
message est fascinant j'ai oublié de le
dire davance plus finalement l'autre hic
est sûre la tracasse tags sur facebook
et les filles ont écrit une toune sera
reboisée malabou faut qu'elle ait
entendu j'espère de tout coeur mais tout
est cool peas a fait une traque inside
qui existaient - qui avait laissé un
message du rinçage
c'est devenu une traque a été construit
co2 en crise que j'ai hâte d'entendre
simplement à cette pop il ya un réel
avantage pour moi c'est lui j'étais
capable d'écouter de suite après de
toute façon j'ai parlé de janeiro titan
pour le reste j'ai clencher 12c mais on
peut quand même pas content c'est comme
vous voulez je veux pas non plus que ma
vessie et comme ce sont sur la zone
souhaitée femme skipper aux sinus et
comme si ce compte il de te le disais la
garde on prend je vais aller me dit
versée si je vous dise en venant à bout
j'ai une question
chose qui met dans sa production tourne
c'est parce que c'est un bon mec je
trouve d'organique d'instruments tous
ceux qui ont été jouées pi2 by making
comment ça comment ça marche c'est quand
est-ce que tu arrives avec un beat peut
être achetée d'instruments lui tout ou
tard je sais que les boys et pitre en
jeu des sommes pas là dessus c'est
qu'est-ce qui vient un coin ça soit les
toons ont tout fait dans mon envie au
départ puis après b sur l'épreuve
on rajoute les instruments ou mais ça
ressemble le pays c'était vraiment ce
l'album c'est un peu
c'était un peu de tout le j'avais
vraiment pas où je m'en allais avec
samuel la première session du studio
qu'on a fait avec les gueux quand j'ai
rencontré mon droit puis mon b 6 ouais
les tours n'étaient pas montés pour
ouvrir le fallait faire des basiques
puis moi je t'ai en plus je suis en
train de tester la nouvelle médication
away pour les je suis gros vive ans le
nombre d'ennemis se demander qu'est ce
qu'on allait faire
je ne savais pas il devait être
connaissait pas tendre avec qui tout
fait désordre à trouver face à cet art
et des baisers des musiciens c est après
s'être acheté des titres offerts placé
en post prod femme métisse fait que ça
dépend des tunes et là maintenant et
j'ai quand même pas une coupe de chop le
début de meeting le beatmaking j'ai fait
un peu d'espionnage industriel
quand même très bien sûr veendam yard
huawei fait maintenant puis c'est quand
même moi j'ai envie de plus arrivent de
plus en plus vers des points qui pousse
est vraiment sur les textes surtout
ouais en fait qu'avec quelque chose de
plus électro moi ça marche quand même
oui
ouais c'était justement faux sur le call
avec le show de la g ce que tu fais ce
que tu fais une recherche de sons par
toi même et tout cas tu veux décider des
tons vraiment unique est ce que tu toi
tu fais ce travail là où comme tu
travailles avec d'autres membres presque
tout un champ qui plaît je suis vraiment
un style un petit napoléon et qui peut
pas partager puis qui veut
je passe beaucoup de temps à fixer le
merlot télam concentré l'apprécié je
fouille dans mes affaires mais l'album
ainsi j'avais pas déjà pas vraiment
d'argent pas trop de gears fait que
c'est beaucoup de sint de logic 7 kg
après tweak et c'est un peu sur le tard
le 2 puis y mettons sur le puits je me
suis acheté un prof athlètes
ouais c'est clair j'apprends j'ai appris
comment gérer comment créer des waves
puis les modifier pour allouer au son
que je veux tu fais que quand maintenant
je suis vraiment être là dessus puis
surtout que la bg comme mon but c'est
d'avoir des tonnes avec le moins de
tracts possible de piste dès mon gros
défi moi c'est d'épurer le truc fait que
c'est là que la recherche de tong est
importante mais oui c'est ça se peut pas
que khalid kolonics parce que la
principauté s'est accroché comme tous
les éléments c'est comme si kanye west
the six mois ce genre moi je veux que
tout soit fort dans le mixer puis si tu
meurs fort [ __ ] passeuse parce que la
traque est passé bonne c'est parce que
la taille coup les leçons et pas assez
bon betty mettons tous les albums comme
il existe deux trois affaires tout
effort kings love peacock sa tombe
il faut s'attendre qui est rigolo on
sait moins gros fans francophones du
tout comme provider ou en mai chainel
barre des 3 de trois instruments puis de
la voix puis jean une myriade de adlib
en arrière de l'huile qui a un peu
triste et fin [ __ ] qu'un chandail
orange est sorti c'est maintenant c'est
esthétique leur minimaliste est plus
présente et béton avec eux c'est juste
du rythme et on suffoque et minimaliste
monotypie fleuri les tombes lance encore
moins mais si tu écoutes des tonnes
quand même
ces insultes
je me souviens quand j'écoutais ce casas
artiste et comme il manque des trucs du
genre y manque ses mangas bullock qui
montrent que le moment ça allait me
manque mais non mais non finalement
c'est comme juste parfait
non il y avait par exemple métier
j'avais jeté justine henin des petits
silicone les beats savoie finalement
même c'est parfait comme c'était mon cas
mais ouais c'est ce genre et nice
seraient blanche
pour moi c'est le graal la chanson n'ont
pas grand chose de meilleur que se situe
la première train avec la voile en
people non non c'est nike is a way non
voyons
voyons comment comment commence l'hiver
m'a écouté ça se poursuit par la seconde
maîtrise c'est finalement c'est jean 3
traque instrumental bâti notre offre qui
font les accords le fond harmonique mais
qui s'alternent fecteau comme la guitare
ainsi depuis un espèce de piano
mélangez avec une guide qui sont gens
vraiment paniqué je me fais couper cocon
chez huawei
c'est encore au moins qui fait des
tonnes way to cook a pu y ait été plus
âpre et helsinki embarquée pas de forme
vraiment labrecque s'est chargé c'est un
long fleuve qui manie le build up avec
les think le noob et guesninois nous
mégane et les new beginning copas de
sangles windham solde des bras puis
maintenant les side cars yves rsa
s'ouvrent le pied mais y'a pas grand
chose puis c'est une fête qui avait pas
grand chose avec les paroles qu'ils
soient justes bien dosé qui donne la
force le ddg pas ça explose qui fait
qu'à une émotion qui passe aussi mène
oui j'ai déchanté fort pas besoin de
vendre est forte c'est juste le dosage
revient tout changer thibault narbonne
romaine et on l'a attendue celle de
citelum après chanel orange c'était
comme acquise à servier deux ans et ça
s'en vient puis saint jean il rapporté
tout aller d'accra ça va venir juillet
2016 c'est quand mais c'est sertic ans
2007-2010 est bon mais le temps passe
vite
en revanche la base et non mais c'est
simple on s'inquiète à raison
weylandt je pense qu'ils venaient bon il
pleuve mon voyage
ah bah oui c'est bon tu vois je te même
pas partie si je faisais n'importe quoi
dans mon voyage à bali
[Rires]
c'est vrai et voilà m n merci beaucoup
d'être venu ouais ça fait plaisir
combien cette partie intégrante de chaud
après deux sorties du happy où on a
quelque chose mais c'est plus je
m'enferme tournée en france suisse
belgique et
en avant mais sinon tout ça va être
genre à 10 tout ces trucs là ouais c'est
cool après il y en a d'autres genres des
vacances au monde à noël c'est ce qu'on
s'attend à ce qu'on souhaite un meilleur
mois le fc sion va essayer
[Rires]